good morning resume the sitting is open
the first item on the agenda is council
and Commission statements situation of
migrants in Bosnia in particular in be
Hutch before I open the debate I would
like to inform you that in order to
request catch the eye and blue cards it
will be possible to use both the
standard registration and the new system
allowing members to register
electronically therefore I invite you to
allow bring your voting card should you
wish to register for catch the eye I
invite you to do so starting from the
point when we finish with the speeches
on behalf of the political groups
without waiting for the end of the
debate the blue cards will be allowed
only after the speeches on behalf of the
political groups are finished the debate
will be open by mrs. to pirinen who
speaks for the council to superintend
the floor is yours honorable mr.
president honorable members of the
Parliament allow me to start by saying
that although serious the Micra Tory
situation in the Western Balkans has
been improving over the last two years
especially 2019 the number of arrivals
in all European migratory routes for the
first three quarters of 2019 was 90
percent lower than last year which is a
positive signal the numbers showed that
the EU is doing its utmost to improve
the general situation and alleviate the
micro tree and humanitarian pressure the
countries in the Western Balkans are
facing however Bosnia and Herzegovina
has become a major route into the EU as
all of us are aware the crisis that
Bosnia and Herzegovina
is currently undergoing is most severe
in the northwest of the country in the
Unison accountant with bahut as its
center the you continues to monitor the
situation on the ground and will do
everything it can to improve the overall
humanitarian situation it is crucial
that the national and local authorities
do their part of the work reach an
agreement and provide refugees and
migrants with proper accommodation we
are committed to helping Bosnia and
Herzegovina deal with this situation and
delivering assistance to the most
vulnerable as the most pressing matter
Bosnia and Herzegovina authorities must
relocate without delay Micron's and
refugees from the unsuitable side of
food shock at meetings with
representatives of the city and cantonal
authorities the EU continues to urge the
immediate closure of this temporary camp
we are also concerned that existing
reception capacities in Bosnia and
Herzegovina remain largely insufficient
the country's office of refugee camps
are full unfortunately in spite of the
years readiness to provide the necessary
financial support the government has not
allocated new sites nor proposed
suitable locations for the needed
additional reception facilities there is
a strong need to ensure effective
functioning of the existing temporary
Inception centers and we take note of
the authority's commitment in this
respect the council defends the dignity
and safety of all persons especially the
most vulnerable ones these persons need
to be protected the presidency would
also like to express its appreciation
for the work of all the humanitarian
partners whose activities must be
facilitated and supported the EU
expresses its readiness to continue
providing additional support
to the affected communities on the
ground by searching at the same time for
more permanent solution the overarching
goal of our efforts is to support Bosnia
and Herzegovina in managing mixed
migration flows in light of the
increasing number of asylum seekers
refugees and migrants arriving in the
country in the past two years when it
comes to the current crisis in Bosnia
and Herzegovina we must work hard to
ensure that the country's authorities at
all levels of government work together
and manage the migration situation in an
effective manner asylum seekers refugees
and migrants now living in deplorable
and difficult conditions must be
allocated adequate premises in line with
the EU requirements there is no time to
wait a swift coordination and reaction
is what is expected from all of us we
need to consolidate our efforts to
resolve the most pressing problems a
permanent solution needs to strengthen
Bosnia and Herzegovina's capacity to
identify and register third country
nationals crossing the border the final
goal should also include the fight
against trafficking in human beings
migrant smuggling and other types of
cross-border crime which is ever-present
in mixed micros and flows Thank You mr.
president
for the ability to speak Thank You mr.
Perrine and I now invite mr.
avramopoulos to speak for the Commission
the floor is yours
Thank You mr. president good morning
dear colleagues honourable members of
the Parliament let me start by welcoming
today's debate about the situation of
refugees and migrants in Bosnia as the
governer it could not have been a more
timely moment as you know the European
Commission is fully informed and closely
following developments including the
extremely poor conditions at the boot
society and in beheads
which not
should have to India what happens in the
region of the Western Balkans effects
all of us affect the rest of Europe to
this why the European Union has always
stood at the side of our Western Balkans
partners as well as the side of the
refugees and migrants in those countries
the debate is even more timely because
the annual Houston Balkans Home Affairs
ministerial takes play place next week
which will give me an opportunity to
discuss the issue with my counterparts
alarm of us to give you the general
picture the wider picture since 2018
around 50,000 people have crossed
through Bosnian service arena on their
way towards Western Europe around 8,000
people remain mostly in the northwest
corner the Unison accountant
the local authorities are bearing the
brunt of migration management the
Commission responded immediately to the
needs of Bosnia and Herzegovina since
the year 2018 we have mobilized over 36
million euros to address the immediate
needs of refugees and migrants and to
strengthen the migration management
capacities of Bosnia and Herzegovina
this includes the 2 million euros
humanitarian assistance that we made
available last month due to the very
limited capacity of the official Sevilla
facilities five temporary reception
centres were set up with EU funds in
2018 providing accommodation for up to
4,000 people
30% of which are families with children
and tenth 10% are unaccompanied minors
this prevented a humanitarian crisis
last winter
now since accommodation capacities
remain insufficient we have repeatedly
earth Bosnia and Herzegovina to identify
suitable additional sites for temporary
reception centers last August we
allocated 10 million years to support
the refurbishment and management of new
centers we have also mobilized a single
expert on migration management to assist
the authorities in their internal
coordination yet despite the significant
resources allocated and the intense
political dialogue we are still awaiting
from the Bosnia and Herzegovina of their
authorities to agree on the location of
Neurosurgery centers and to increase the
capacities of existing centers moreover
the fourth
disembarkation from trains and buses and
the limiting of magnets access to
services has contributed to the
deterioration of the humanitarian
situation we are therefore discussing
with key partners how to help the
authorities to best address the most
urgent needs of migrants and refugees
especially the most vulnerable groups at
the same time we have raised with the
authorities the risk of a humanitarian
crisis in the coming winter and now let
me come back to the situation in because
we cannot accept the continuing
transfers of migrants and the refugees
to the entire entire unsuitable location
of woods where the health and lives
of people are being put at serious risk
by the lack of access to water
sanitation shelter and protection
similar concerns have been expressed by
the United Nations agencies the site is
a former landfill close to minefields it
does not fulfill the minimal
requirements for decent reception
conditions therefore no EU finances
support can or will be provided for it I
want to be very clear on that
we have asked him the local authorities
to dismantle the site without further
delay and move the persons currently
accommodated there to adequate
facilities we take note as the first
positive step or the decision taken this
week by the government of the Federation
entity to approve the use of to military
barracks is temporary reception centers
in a place called blasted near Sarajevo
and Nabatean or Tuzla we now expect such
decision to be implemented swiftly in
order to relieve the pressure on the
onus on us
Canton and the transfer of the persons
currently in butas let me also add let
me also say that we remain concerned
about alleged cases of violent push
backs and mistreatment of migrants at
the Croatian border with Bosnia and
Herzegovina we take such reports from
civil society and international
organizations very very seriously any
form of violence against the fugitive
migrants is unacceptable we are in close
contact with
the authorities of Croatia we have
committed to investigating allegations
of mistreatment of migrants refugees at
its external borders and to keeping the
Commission informed in this context upon
request of the Commission a monitoring
mechanism has been established and at
ensuring that the border control
activities by the Croatian border guard
officers remain fully compliant with
with EU law international obligations
and with the respect of fundamental
rights and the rights resulting from the
EU as I'll rules I recently visited
against Zagreb in the context of our
evaluation of Croatia's readiness to
join Schengen their commitment was again
reiterated at this occasion honourable
members despite all the support that we
have provided the heavy pressure and
iteration in Bosnia and Herzegovina
remains deeply concerning especially in
light of the upcoming winter we all want
to avoid a worsening illustration and a
new humanitarian crisis we are doing all
we can to help Bosnia and Herzegovina to
address the situation the dignity and
safety of all affected persons needs to
be ensured and protected we will
continue engaging with the contents
authorities as well as with civil
society and international organizations
from the ground on these very pressing
issues I know that this house shares the
same concerns and I'm looking forward to
hearing your views today thank you very
much for attention thank you very much
we follow what
statements by